news Bailey from science mission
scientists show that rhythmic firing
pattern on neurons during chewing
breathing etc depends on the regulation
of extracellular calcium concentrations
by astrocytes they also show that
calcium binding protein s hundred beta
is required for this rhythmic activity
of neurons next neuronal mechanisms arre
functions are not clearly understood
other show that addiction receptors
through their interaction with the TRP
channels modulate sensitivity of
neuronal mechanisms ation next
scientists have come up with the
framework to map how antibiotic may be
acting in the gut to cause disease later
in life related to obesity antibiotic
induced changes in the gut microbiota
resulted in increased levels of
short-chain fatty acids that affect
metabolism in the case of allergies the
use of antibiotics may eradicate key gut
bacteria that help immune cells mature
in the infectious diseases antibiotic
use may help the gut is access to
pathogens for more details visit us at
www.hsn Smith and Facebook page thanks
for watching